later downtown's new circuit resort is
celebrating its grand opening tonight
the hotel tower we're talking about it
is the tallest north of the las vegas
strip
it officially opens today just in time
for new year's eve celebrations
hector mejia is live to show us around
hector i understand you've recently been
on an elevator
i have and you know what this is really
cool the view you're seeing right now is
from
inside the elevator up on the 60th floor
and as soon as those elevator doors open
this is the view people will see as they
get up here at uh
legacy club these are metal busts of
some of the founding fathers here in las
vegas including
howard hughes and many others also benny
binyan and off here we have
right there that is the view of the las
vegas strip
there we have downtown off in the
distance the stratton you know what a
lot of work is going on right now as
crews
make sure this place is ready to go and
then off here we have a lot of
oil paintings of more uh founding
fathers here in las vegas there you see
benny binyan baron hilton
howard hughes off here and then you know
there's even more
actually before we walk even more i left
my name here
for tonight's festivities legacy club
opens at 4pm
and right here this is a really cool
thing those are
gold bars valued at 1.8 million dollars
that's another attraction here
i bet you every single security camera
is pointing in that direction
making sure nobody steals any of those
bars but as we were mentioning earlier
a lot of work is going on right now this
is the 60th floor
and what's also neat is that a lot of
hotel guests
were able to check in two days in
advance today is the official opening
date for the
for the tower the hotel tower but people
are already in their bed right now
uh enjoying the view enjoying the room
and this is another part of the hotel
that gets to open today legacy club a
lot of work is going on right now
this is actually our home base for all
of our new year's eve festivities all of
our new year's eve coverage
uh we'll be broadcasting live from up
here at legacy club and also
downstairs at stadium swim and
we'll be going outside to show you what
the view looks like
pretty cool panoramic views of the
downtown area for now reporting live
hector mejia 8 news now back to you guys